in diesen 18 jahren gelernt hat was es
heißt zu führen und die vor allen dingen
gelernt hat das ist bei führung näher
auf die innere stärke als auf die äußere
lautstärke ankommt das muss mal gesagt
werden
in dieser welt mit all den lautsprechern
da draußen monate etwa die cdu braucht
um nach der ankündigung von angela
merkel sie wolle nicht mehr für den
parteivorsitz kandidieren eine neue
vorsitzenden zu wählen
jetzt kann man also sagen in den letzten
wochen als das unklar war als die
bewerbungen liefen
da war die formulierung natürlich immer
eine oder ein er jetzt an geld kam
kranbauer gewählt worden
das nehmen wir die wahl an und bedanke
mich für das vertrauen und ich bedanke
mich an dieser stelle ganz ganz herzlich
insbesondere bei jens spahn insbesondere
bei friedrich merz für diesen fairen
wettbewerb den wir uns geliefert haben
allerdings mit einer denkbar knappen
mehrheit und auch erst mal zweiter
wahlgang
das heißt die partei ist offensichtlich
zweigeteilt sein lager wenn man das so
nennen kann das verschmerzen hängt das
vielleicht mal ein anderes image gewollt
hätte man möglicherweise auch an der
spitze auch das sollte man ganze gering
achten dass das vielleicht eine rolle
gespielt hat nun ist die entscheidung
knapp gegen märz und für kramp
karrenbauer ausgefallen nun wird sie
alle hände voll damit zu tun haben
zu zeigen dass sie trotzdem für die
ganze partei steht und diese zusammen zu
halten
das wird nicht leicht werden allerdings
märz gezeigt dass er nicht mit aller
kraft und aller energie für die cdu
einsetzen will hat sich nicht für einen
der ämter in der partei führung geworfen
und damit auch gar nicht erst meine eine
dauerhafte konkurrenz entstehen können
innerhalb der partei
die schlacht oder das wettrennen auch
kampagnen bauer gegen märz wird jetzt
zumindest in form der beiden personen
nicht fortgesetzt
[Applaus]